does anyone know of people like Michio
Kaku that can explain String Theory like
he does for people like me and I'm not a
genius well I am Michio Kaku and I'd be
glad to answer that question first of
all most textbooks say that an electron
is a DOT particles that we see in our
atom Smashers are dots but if I had a
super microscope I could see that that
dot is actually a rubber band from a
distance this rubber band looks like a
DOT close up you see that it's a
vibrating string now this rubber band
can vibrate in many different modes each
mode can be called the particle so for
example this might be an electron but if
you totally in a different way
it becomes a quark and if you twirl it
this way you have to give it a different
name we call it a neutrino